that's one is a new york mets game that
you brought it up
can you pull up this video please yeah
one's a new york mets game and i want to
show this to you and then the other one
is uh uh
john kerry refusing to wear a mask even
though he makes everybody in the world
wear one
here's what happens at a new york mets
uh starting from the beginning
and make it bigger kai nets and yankees
by the way
go all the way to the back watch this so
mets and yankees this one guy
the security is asking him to take off
the mega hat is what the security is
asking him to do
and then watch what this other not
caucasian
guy is telling them to do with the hat
watch this well the whole crowd really
[Music]
[Applause]
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
put the hat back on bro put it on put it
on
[Applause]
put it on
the new yorkers have so much charisma
you know there's other videos too if you
scroll down you'll see a wider shot of
it where the whole section is going nuts
the whole stadium is actually cheering
for it it's not maga
doesn't mean donald trump anymore it
means anti this establishment
is what it's turning into it doesn't
mean i mean that those were clearly
white supremacists obviously so i mean
it's that's a focus group right there go
go to
go to the other video with me such a
disconnect between
the world our media tells us
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you've
not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]
you